the national education association
recently stated despite the momentous
efforts of educators during the pandemic
online learning has never been an
effective replacement for
in-person learning we know school
closures harm low income students the
most
because they have less access to high
quality remote learning
president trump making the case to
reopen schools stressing the importance
of
in-person learning and the economic
benefits of schools and child care
u.s secretary of education betsy devos
joins us now and secretary devos thank
you for joining us we very much
appreciate it
it seems to me and i want to put these
gallup polls up on the screen it seems
to me and to a lot of americans
that this push to get in-person learning
is losing a little bit of steam
you see there from may 25th to june 8 56
of the population said they wanted
in-person full-time
school and you move forward to july
and now it's down to 36 percent so the
whole push seems to be losing steam
what does the administration think about
that
well we we know that it's a coordinated
effort
in a campaign to continue to sow fear
and yet when you look at facts and when
you look at the science
we know that the important thing for
kids is to be able to get back into
school
into their classrooms back with their
peers back with their teachers
and learning in person and for most
students this
is the case there are some for whom it's
not the right answer
but we need kids back in school learning
as secretary azar has rightfully said
this is a matter of health versus health
children's mental growth and well-being
their social emotional growth their
their development all of it relates to
a continued effort to make sure students
have the opportunity to back be back in
school full time
you talk about following the science and
you mentioned secretary azar and you
know back in june the cdc was saying
that you know the risk to children
appears to be very low well we've had a
little bit of a change since
then because now you have the american
academy of pediatrics and the children's
hospital association if i can put this
on the screen
between july 9th and august 6th there
were 179
plus thousand cases of children getting
the coronavirus that's an increase of
90 percent over four weeks does that
number give you pause at all secretary
well we know that children are going to
get the virus
adults are going to get the virus but
the the facts have been
uh that the virus has not impacted
children
in the same way that even the average
flu season does
the number of of children that have
actually succumbed to the virus versus
the flu
is like one-sixth the amount of an
annual rate
and so again the focus really needs to
be
on doing the right things you know the
cdc has provided
a lot of guidance and a lot of
recommendations
many schools have reopened and they're
doing so successfully when they follow
this guidance
and they take the matter seriously but
the point is
they're doing the things some of them
hard some of them
unusual for you know a normal school
circumstance
but they're doing the things that need
to be done to get
kids back into the classroom and back
into their learning
yeah the president floating this idea
secretary devos of
having the money follow the children and
the schools that open giving them some
money and the schools that don't pulling
back some money and giving it to the
kids
the pushback has been pretty severe from
democrats and
educators across the country your
thoughts on that
well we make a promise when we invest in
education and that is to actually
educate
children and that promise is made to
their families and if they're
if that is not going to happen the
president's absolutely
absolutely right parents should have the
power
to take those resources and find a
school or an environment that's going to
work for them
we're seeing a lot of schools a lot of
charter schools a lot of private schools
that are successfully reopening and
we need to ensure that parents and
children have these options as well
yeah it's interesting because you know
you see a lot of these patchwork plans
around the country and i lastly just
want to
put this up there because georgia
schools seem to be a lot of focus
there's a lot of conversation about
what's happening there they open
59 confirmed cases they've got more than
a thousand students quarantined
this appears to be what might happen you
understand the risk and you believe that
everybody is still on board in the
administration with going forward and
saying you know what we're going to have
some setbacks
but in the end there are kids that need
student meals they need
internet they need supervision and they
need to get back in school
they need to get back in school and
again the cdc has provided
very good information very good
recommendations and guidance
and and have have laid out uh procedures
for
recommendations for what to do when you
do have a case or
a couple of cases in a school and and if
those things are followed and uh though
they're taken seriously
a lot of this can be addressed very
effectively we're seeing it in many
schools across the country
and we're going to continue to see it
more as those that are committed to
doing what's right for kids
actually do provide in-person learning
and provide
them the option of being there five days
a week
learning moving ahead as they should be
doing
you know a kid's only seven one time in
their life
you can't get that time back and that's
true for
children of all ages education secretary
betsy devos ma'am thank you so much
thanks trace